[Music]
welcome back river babes
I'm your host Leon Aguilera and this is
your Sweetwater Secrets after-show for
episode 405 witness for the prosecution
I'm going to be really honest with you
guys like I always am I thought this
episode was fine now aside from that
flash-forward it was air I say a little
boring and that's really saying
something considering we had hooded
vigilantes surprise sisters and serial
killer revelations nevertheless I have a
very unborn interview with you from the
lovely Camila Mendes spilling on
Veronica's oh so crazy life anta will be
going over your top hisses and kisses of
the week so get ready for that
but first let's quickly recap the
biggest moments of the episode what's
the blue and gold breakdown all right
now this episode was split into four
parts with very little character
crossover so this will be a very easy
episode to discuss easy just not that
exciting first up Archie aka Riverdale's
vigilante with a black hood costume okay
now as you can see in this side-by-side
comparison the costumes are very similar
why would they do this I have no idea
now if they had just waited a few more
months the Green Arrow costume would
have been up for grabs on the CW because
that's what it feels like I'm watching
but I guess they just grabbed what was
left in the season two costume box
anyways costume crankiness aside Archie
held a press conference to let the town
know that the community centers gonna be
having a Big Brother Big Sister program
but Dodger is still their biggest
obstacle in town so Archie borrowed
Oliver Queen's voice changer and
threatened Dodger to leave town once and
for all I doubt that's gonna happen next
up Betty
now our blonde beauty grabbed sweet may
be Kevin and started her junior FBI
course with Charles but then she quickly
realized that her ability to spot serial
killers could be linked to her genes in
a particularly twisted moment Betty
realized that when she was little her
cat caramel was hit by a car and her
deranged father made her kill it with a
rock oh my god now by the end of the
episode Betty realized two things number
one
Charles also apparently has the serial
killer genes and number two she really
doesn't trust Charles but who does as
for Jughead
well he's still at that awful school but
the silver lining for him is that a long
line of ghost riders for the baxter
brothers books attended Stonewall prep
so he did his quest for knowledge
Jughead reel as his grandfather was a
writer too and since his grandpa was the
one who first sparked his love for the
book series jug or should we say for
says the third is now looking to be the
next author oh and then we had this
flash forward scene Archie Andrews Betty
Cooper and Veronica Lodge you're under
arrest for the cold-blooded murder of my
son Jughead Jones
[Music]
okay still not buying it
lastly let's talk about Veronica now I'm
still not clear on the legalese of these
storylines but long story short she was
working on getting her mom at a jail and
keeping her dad behind bars but a
surprising newbie showed up and ruined
everything ladies in River babe's meet
Hermosa Lodge Hiram's other daughter ah
there's two of them too
Hiram's not two Veronica's I'd gladly
take two Veronica's so while we try to
process what's going on with thee let's
take a look at what cami had to tell me
when I was with her on set Veronica
Lodge is the hardest working woman in
Riverdale she owns la bonne nuit pops
chocolate shop yep she shows up
everywhere looking sensational she's a
vixen she's a vixen and I'm sure she's
still probably pulling in straight A's
yeah oh yeah she's like on the
harvard-trained oh yeah yeah put that in
writing what is coming up for her this
year how is she be balancing all of it
and on top of that you know her parents
are kind of both in jail Veronica's one
of those people that just like balances
things I don't know I wouldn't know
about that but she just manages to do it
all mm-hmm um so she's running her
businesses and getting straight A's
and her parents are in jail and she's
she's currently living at home alone
well with the supervision of smithers
who isn't really there ever so it's a
lot of unsupervised barchi moments and
sleepovers um it's pretty nice I like to
think so in season three
you went toe-to-toe with Mark Consuelos
so many times where you guys had heated
yelling scenes but in reality mark is
like the nicest guy ever I know what was
that like for you to like tap into that
turn that on with him mark and I I love
doing scenes with Mark but because when
we show up to set it's like like we
gonna have fun but we're also very in
the zone cuz usually our scenes require
a lot of focus and a lot of like
vindictive lines and you just kind of
have to be in his own I don't know that
I could do what me and KJ do in a scene
like that you know because KJ night
we'll just constantly try to make each
other laugh but when it's me and Mark
were very very intense and very focused
he's a great scene partner
you do have a history we will be getting
Veronica higher moments lots of visits
and jail both Hermione and Hyrum who are
both there so that means we'll be seeing
more Monika posh I know we're all dying
to see more at Monica's is kami dying to
see Monica posh cami doesn't like
wearing the Monika posh wig but Kimmy
will deal I'm sorry so she can't be
herself visiting her parents no I guess
not
okay no more fun with Monica it's more
fun more fun you would know I mean we
try that's what we tried you'd know
about that what I love cami and I love
all of our Riverdale couples so now
let's take a look at the most romantic
moments of the night list seven seconds
in heaven oh yeah that's right there
were no romantic moments cool so let's
move on to something we can actually
talk about with hisses and kisses all
right guys I called out on Twitter and
you guys flooded my mentions with all of
your hisses and kisses so our first
tweet said kisses to Jughead in the
Stonewall prep storyline hisses Juno
Shoni yup and Lee Ann question for you
do you ship Kevin and Charles hash tag
Carl's no I do not ship Kevin and
Charles I ship Kevin with someone normal
and not Shady he's had enough awful
relationships to be going through all
that so that is just a - no that's a no
from me guys we are getting in so many
amazing comments right now let's see
let's see we have one from Nica Guam Oh
says I need the Serpent's I completely
agree where have the serpents gone
okay so Jughead just leaves did he
abandon them this is just deep stuff you
guys it's like the writers think that we
are not noticing it but we are I love
the Riverdale writers but they're just
like maybe if we just don't mention the
serpent's everyone will forget that we
spent two whole seasons building them up
I don't know about that okay excellent
gene Oh excellent ginger sorry I'm so
over the hooded vigilante Archie
stuff yeah me too
me too yeah we're gonna get into that in
just a little bit Lia Oh Freddie said
hisses - no Shani my favorite couple
ever yeah I completely agree with that
and then we also had a bunch of other
people who were saying that there is no
Shani but you know what maybe they've
got a lot going on
this'll house so I agree hisses to that
let's let them deal with that I'd also
like to give hisses to the bat the fact
that Betty can no longer reference the
Nancy Drew books yeah who else caught
the line when she referred to them as
the Tracey true books Oh Toto we are so
not in season two anymore that was just
weird yeah we have another tweet from
Shelley Marie and she said well I love
catch up was acting hisses to Archie's
storyline stop making him an impulsive
vigilante especially with the black hood
and why is it always so literally dark
in his scenes that face needs to be in
bright light
I completely agree and you guys seem to
agree as well the Archie vigilante
storyline makes no sense to me I
understand that Archie's going through a
lot and like I said last week I'm giving
him about six episodes to do whatever he
wants to do because I feel like I can't
tell him what to do he's been through a
lot but I don't want it I don't like
that it's a black hood I wouldn't want
to see him in a costume anyways but
honestly if I wanted to see a story
about a vigilante I would watch arrow
and I do and it's great I watched
Riverdale for the other weird stuff okay
Emily at Roth Miller says I missed
barchi in this episode you guys I think
we were talking so much that we wanted
more core four and I feel like we should
have specified that we want more core
four scenes together not just core four
because they each had their own separate
storylines and while it's great for them
we have no crossover at all and no group
scenes at all so okay okay natural
beauty one two oh eight says hisses - no
Shoni but I feel like we needed a break
from all the mess going on in thistle
house that was the comment I was looking
for I completely agree it's just
not ideal Paulina says hisses to Betty's
storyline why would she think she's a
serial killer just because of genes I
actually did so much research on this
damn serial killer gene storyline and
you know what after reading a bunch of
articles I still have no idea what's
going on I'm sure that this is based off
of something that's linked to something
but I just can't and also here was what
was so weird why would they have it that
caramel was killed by a rock when in
Betty's weird cult dream sequence when
it was Paulie talking to her they said
they drowned the cat why would they
change the way the cat was killed also
do not kill any cats I can't believe I
had to say that today so yeah okay Lanie
daga knelt sorry if I said that wrong
said his sister Hal for making Betty
kill her cat exactly kisses to bug head
kisses to Kevin and Betty's friendship
making a comeback and hisses to the
writers for making Charles bad yes I
just feel like we're just in like a
little mouse wheel just going round and
round and round yeah let's let's read a
tweet unique Carolyn said hisses to
Hiram and Hermosa for just being them
also hisses to Brett the psycho kid
kisses to Jughead and his going back to
stonewall and continuing with his real
name and also kisses to Kevin for just
being there as a normal friend to Betty
again yes it is so great to see let's
just destroyed my set you guys I'm so
upset because you talked about Kevin and
I could really fire it up um yes it's so
nice to see Kevin on our screens again
and it's so nice to see him as a friend
to Betty but I would love Kevin to have
a storyline instead of just being a
support for Betty yes she's going
through a lot and it's great that he's
there for her but truly it's were in
four seasons in give him his own thing
he's cute enough and don't have him like
keep pining after Charles I am not here
for that no no no no things I am here
for though a reporter Alice kisses -
reporter Alice just look at her she's
perfect and I'm very pleased to say that
she's holding her mic correctly and
overall she's just doing a great job
considering she was
masquerading as a cult follower and
killed its leader yay Alice just look at
her so good just holding it well
Mei Chen you know I love you I know your
hubby's watching right now well done
girl well done love it
let's take a couple more comments Polly
Bharath de Jong said uh when does Archie
sleep if he's out at night and he's also
apparently at the community center all
day and I can't with this community
center you guys I just can't I get that
he's wanting to make Riverdale a better
place but when was it ever a bad place
it's like there was like seedy little
parts of town but over the past four
seasons it's now this like Gotham what
is happening and we're Dodger you know
what if you brought back penny Peabody
I'd be more excited out and care about
Dodger no and you know what this is
perfect this is gonna lead us to our
poll I tweeted last night and I asked
you all which character was the biggest
troublemaker this week out of Charles
Brett Dodger and Hermosa and Hermosa won
by a landslide kind of it was Hermosa at
40% Brett at 32% and you know what
Charles just just is a bug so what I
actually wanted to say that instead of
like who was the biggest troublemaker I
just want to say who bugged the hell out
of you the most but I thought that
wasn't very kind to write on Twitter I
let's talk about her most lunch
the fact that it's Veronica's sister
like older half-sister kind of bothers
me because I feel like we just got a
mysterious half person for the Cooper
Joneses if it was Veronica's aunt that
to me I feel like would make a little
bit more sense like as if it's like
Hiram's like super loyal sister and and
maybe that would be more of a strange
situation the actress that they got to
play her most it looks sensational rock
the pearls girl you look fantastic got
my little nod to you over here but I
just I feel like the Riverdale
storylines are kind of just blowing in a
bit of a hamster wheel right now it's
like okay let's take the same storyline
but put it with this character and
I don't think so okay he had a girl six
three zero nine five get a girl said I
think all the flash-forwards scenes are
part of the murder story Jughead is
writing for his contact contests his
quote perfect murder is his own death
dun-dun-dun I think you're right and you
know what we have a tweet from Renata
Ayala and she agrees and she said I have
a theory after tonight's episode they
either faked jugheads death as a decoy
or it's just Jughead imagining the
scenes of the book he needs to write to
win the competition PS I think his
grandfather will appear soon I
completely agree I thought it was very
strange in the flash-forward scene that
FP would barge into a classroom and and
say in front of everyone like for the
cold blood murder of my son it felt very
theatrical and it felt like it could be
like a dream sequence almost or like he
was trying it seemed like they were all
in on something and especially how they
like went over to Reggie's like reaction
and be like I don't know I'm not buying
that you guys I'm not buying it and it
stinks because it's 405 and I would like
to at least be like teased a little bit
more but you know what it's all good
Brett Evans says where's jugheads mom
surely she's behind some of the madness
oh yes I would love to see Gladys come
back for a little bit because I thought
Gina Gershon did a great job who else
thought it was really bizarre that FP
did a complete 180 and was just really
anti Stonewall when as drug had said he
was the one who was pressuring him to go
to the school maybe he's just touchy
about his dad's stuff maybe he's got
daddy issues doesn't everyone in
Riverdale they all do
Vivian cow said FP once again said that
his dad drank himself to death so
consistency in Riverdale isn't really a
thing yeah yeah just yeah okay
let's see we have a tweet from Tai Chi
allo said hisses to the farm for still
messing things up in Riverdale when
Edgar is dead yeah I was thinking about
that like how was Alice not in trouble
but then I realised it was self-defense
so okay
r.i.p Edgar you
beautiful crazy man Victoria Bichette
said kisses to Jughead for being Willy
to for being willing to pursue his
dreams despite so many hurdles hisses to
these confusing flash-forward scenes yes
and while we're on the subject of hisses
let's talk about Brett who I'm now going
to rename the guy I want to punch in his
smug face I've never thought that I
would want to punch someone so hard I
never will and I'm sure the actor is
fantastic because it takes a lot to play
a character like that but the character
of Brett is the worst and are we just
supposed to believe that Marmaduke
really is in the army he just showed up
and then he's gone we're supposed to
trust Jonna do not trust Donna don't
like her nope nope nope I'm tired of all
these people bringing someone new that
we can like new actually or just give us
the scenes of the characters that we
have like with Shoni you guys I'm just
rambling at this point because oh yeah
and Aaron says kisses to Jughead for
standing up for himself against Brett
you know what Brett's like 45 so he
needs to get a life or a hobby or
something all right you guys and I think
we're gonna end it right there because
everybody's just an agreement that Oh
Carlotta screw can great comment to end
it on girl this is great can we talk
about the fact that nobody has biology
in their senior year I completely did
not even think about that but you're
right I took biology freshman year but I
know that it was a freshman sophomore
class and wow I'm having some really
intense high school flashbacks but yes
who's taking biology their senior year
unless it's an AP bio class which I
don't even think you can do that yes
clearly we need to get a high school
curriculum over to the Riverdale staff
this was fun you guys these are good
ones one more one more clothes master
said kisses to Jughead for finally
showing Brett what he's made of and
hisses to Veronica's sister hermosa she
just seems sketchy so yes once again
Hermosa welcome to Riverdale you're very
beautiful your pearls are great but if
you act a lot like higher and we're not
gonna get along that's okay that's okay
I understand why you're here but I just
don't need anymore
lodge's right now we're focusing on the
Lunas we're gonna be done thank you so
much for watching today's after-show and
be sure to join us next week on sweet
letter secrets because we're gonna be
going over Riverdale episode 406 chapter
63 hereditary that sounds like a Cheryl
episode I'm cool for that now but for us
you know what I'm about to say give this
video a like hit subscribe so you never
miss an episode and then head on down to
the comments or tweet me with your
thoughts who else thinks the Jughead is
dead storyline has really overkill pun
totally intended did anyone ask for
hermosa Lodge to arrive No and which of
our core four story lines are you liking
the most right now which are you like in
the least tell me everything and I'll
talk to you soon river babes kisses to
you
[Music]